uh hope everyone is nice and awake uh so
our first speaker is Yasmin Vari from
deepmind she's done a lot of cool work
at the intersection of physics and
learning theory and deep learning trying
to understand uh kind of you know what
makes deep learning tick and today she's
going to be talking to us about neural
scaling laws
can you all hear me great um thank you
for the kind introduction also the
invitation to speak this workshop with
really an amazing
um kind of list of speakers
um so the topic I'd like to talk about
today is some of our now older work
trying to kind of understand uh scaling
laws
um sort of from first principles but in
a way that's also trying to kind of uh
match with experiments so that's
something that I I care a lot about
um and so
um just to start kind of jump directly
into the material
there are a lot of basic scaling knobs
that we can use in machine learning
um so things like the amount of training
data the size of the model the amount of
the of compute that we have or the time
and so the question we're gonna be
tackling
um at the beginning uh kind of in the
first parts of this talk is to ask what
is the average performance of a machine
learning model as a function of some of
these basic scaling variables
and uh certainly you know some aspects
of this problem fit into classic uh
learning theory particularly when you
focus on kind of how an ml model
improves as you scale the amount of
training data then maybe one of the new
ingredients as we'd like to kind of
understand a few of these variables all
together and in a way kind of bridge the
gap with with experiments so why study
this now
um
it's really motivated by empirical
observations and large models both in
the kind of vision setting and in
language and so uh you know this paper
now a few years from a few years ago by
Kaplan McCandless uh kind of uh Point
really uh kind of pointed this out uh
pretty starkly at a empirical level
um they uh you know looked at the
scaling of test loss in large language
models as a function of these basic
variables saw that they follow tend to
follow kind of nice smooth Trends as a
function of these three basic variables
with these exponents for the power laws
that I've kind of listed here
um so that's the problem we're going to
be talking about mostly for for this
talk I won't get to talk about other
very important knobs
um which are kind of uh also important
to understand both in theory and
practice like data quality and the
diversity
um of the of the data set so more
examples of some scaling laws so this is
now changing the metric it's looking
more at accuracy this is from the gpt3
paper also really high highlighted um
uh kind of this this Behavior and the
way in which performance changes when
you drastically change the the model
size for a problem like in context
learning
um and here you can see kind of the
aggregate Behavior performance uh for
gpt3 across um uh kind of a wide range
of benchmarks as a function of the model
size
so there's a lot of empirical work now
on uh kind of trying to find the best
way to scale
um where best kind of depends on the
setting
um
in practice that you want to work in but
it often might mean the compute optimal
way to scale so you have access to a
certain amount of compute and you would
like to figure out how to divide that
compute up amongst the amount of data
that you have in the model size and so
on and so there are often these in the
literature from the empirics there
people have researchers have used these
kind of functional forms that are often
of the following form if I just think
about the two variables D and P the
amount of training data the model size
there might be a constant shift plus
some leading kind of power law terms and
there might be more complicated forms
out there fits to the data as well but
we kind of would like to understand
um you know see if we can say some
things about this sorry does the amount
of compute also enter into the formula
so uh it um it could it could oftentimes
well the computers might be like uh
depending on the model that they train
it's related to the amount of data and
the number of parameters and so that you
could plug that in as a constraint and
then like solve for but
um and uh yeah solve for the um kind of
optimal values so
um it's true that compute is often one
of the main variables that we're going
to look at in practice so what we're
going to be looking at I'll be talking
about is mostly training data and model
size but it's easy to incorporate
compute in the setting that I am going
to talk about
so let me now break this down into maybe
uh some specific set of questions that I
think are interesting so can we say
anything more about these empirical
Trends so what are some types of
questions we would like to ask for
example what aspect of the data and the
models determine the functional forms if
we can say anything about that at all
for example are the exponents for data
and model scaling ever the same
or are they always different so you know
is is are some
is the problem More Sample efficient
compared to parameter efficient or is
there some symmetry between these things
um are all scaling regimes quote-unquote
the same or are some different so
something kind of approaching a taxonomy
or a classification
um so by saying I mean
um kind of the thing that drives the
Improvement in performance is the same
sort of uh uh you know has the same
underlying cause which you could see in
the theory or like more mechanistically
it's it's more obviously the same or are
there kind of different things different
uh
uh kind of more mechanistic reasons uh
behind this and I'll try to say that I
think different scaling regimes do have
different Origins
um and then is there for example any
empirically observable Universal
Behavior or is the whole problem just
too dependent on microscopic in quotes
microscopic details meaning that um you
know for your particular setup the
problem depends so much on you know the
type of training data that that you have
in the model architecture and so on that
it doesn't make sense to try to tackle
this problem theoretically you would
just go out and measure the exponents
and that would be it or measure the
functional forms and usually you do
Theory when you believe that some not
every not every aspect of the problem is
uh highly dependent on the microscopic
details you would like to understand
maybe if there are more general
principles behind this
so one caveat is that a lot of this talk
since uh this is a little bit of older
work uh and uses a bit of theory focuses
on images as the domain but some is
going to be applicable to llms and I'll
try to
um kind of remember to point that out as
we as we go along
um before I start I just want to
acknowledge uh my collaborators with
whom this work is done
um many of them at two of them at a deep
mind
Ethan Dyer Lee and Jerry Kaplan of
course Sharma were at Johns Hopkins so
all of us have backgrounds in
theoretical physics
and so the kind of tools and ideas we
use are kind of either limited or
inspired by that
so the approach that um you'll see I
kind of taken this talk and I like more
generally is to start with Simple Theory
in a place where you have um kind of a a
nice handle on the problem and then in
places where you don't have Theory you
can try to test out some things
empirically
um and so start simple and work your way
up uh in complexity and we did this by
basically setting a simpler setting and
then figuring out what we could
generalize uh even to to other regimes
um so I kind of like this back and forth
between doing some Theory doing some
experiments
um to kind of confirm that and feedback
in into Theory so just a few slides um
feel bear with me of what the problem
setup is and then
um we won't have so much of the
formality so the theory problem is the
kind of classic one
um that some folks in the audience might
be familiar with
um we would like to learn a Model F sub
Theta with learnable parameters Theta
for the data distribution P it's classic
supervised learning
in this setting we're thinking about
images for example and we have a
training data set D we have some
empirical loss it could be I've written
down MSC but it could also be cross
entropy and then we minimize it to
obtain parameters Theta hat and the
Learned model we would like to evaluate
the population loss so evaluate kind of
this error on the true distribution
that we don't actually know and there's
a further dependence on other aspects of
the problem like the initial condition
Theta naught for the parameters that you
might use in when you initialize for
optimization for example as well as the
draw of the training data set so we'll
also average over those quantities
unlike a
so some work often times will just focus
on a fixed straw of the training set and
maybe get kind of worst case uh bounds
we uh kind of would like to consider
fully averaged quantities
um so we get this smooth thing
um smooth uh thing that is the loss as a
function of the amount of data and the
number of model parameters
so um now to to take a look at talk
about different architectures you can
keep in the back of your mind for
example a vanilla fully connected
network but it doesn't have to be fully
connected we can also discuss other
architectures and it has a depth L and
in terms of the most basic kind of
features of the model there's a depth to
it and there's a hidden layer with so L
and n that I'll use and a fixed kind of
fixed size input
um and again Theta refers to the set of
learnable parameters and there are P
total parameters so I'm going to be
relying on some results kind of from
Deep learning theory that are applicable
to different model types
so not just fully connected layers but
could be convolutional residual and even
attention layers I'll come back to
um
to some caveats with models that have
attention in in their architecture in a
bit but in terms of the kind of the most
cartoon basic way of thinking about the
model you know the number of parameters
P could be increasing because the depth
is increasing or the width is is
increasing or there's some joint scaling
and so those
um we would like to kind of incorporate
ideally all of those into this into this
way of scaling into understanding
scaling
so
to just reiterate we're going to
consider this fully average quantity
the number of parameters as I mentioned
can grow in in two different ways or or
perhaps multiple ways with this joint
scaling
um and because of some of our
limitations on the theory side and in
terms of What's Understood really well
in deep learning theory
we're actually going to study the loss
as a function of the data set size and
the width so the over you know the over
under parametrization is going to come
from changing just the size of the
Hidden layers in the network but keeping
the deck the depth fixed and what we'll
be able to extract are power law
terms that or the form of the power laws
um in that look like this so we might
just focus on scaling with the amount of
training data and look at the exponent
for that scaling or look at the scaling
with the width or the model size
and extract that exponent so I'm mostly
going to focus on these exponents Alpha
D and Alpha W sometimes I'll use Alpha W
interchangeably with Alpha P because
it's labeling width or parameters but
these are the two exponents for which
we're going to be able to say some
things about different regimes and
values that they might take
so in unfortunately that is we we can't
access from the theory side a joint
scaling so that's that's that is a
limitation yeah
um I the ideal treatment would kind of
focus on both DNN scaling together but
in the background I'll say this in you
know in terms of what's known on the
Deep learning theory side
um those limits can be hard child not a
lot is known about them and I also ask
on only focusing
can I also ask on only focusing on with
I mean so from a theory side width is
easy because we know you get Universal
function approximators with big width
but it sort of seems like for a deep
learning and practice side
only talk about with and not depth is
kind of uninteresting
so that's a good uh question I think
so
it's maybe a bit sharper than top than
Universal approximation because we're
gonna in the background you're gonna be
relying on results about what is learned
and so what is learned in in these large
width limits a lot more is known about
that and it's it's more specific than
just you know we know things about the
functional form that's learned there are
some relationships to kernels and and
other things that I'll talk about so I
think it's more it certainly does
capture some aspects of depth that I'll
talk about but I think it's more
specific than just Universal
approximation in terms of the
um
uh kind of constraints
and and also we'll um
yeah well we'll I guess is it reasonable
to ignore depth
it's it's not gonna
um from the theory side we
I think the movies
so depth will be in there but it just
won't be scaled yeah I don't think death
is getting ignored I think it's just not
being taken to infinity and that is it
is important that um I mean there are
other interesting limits where depth and
width would be scaled together for
example and maybe training data would
either be much less or scaled with that
and those are just challenging to access
theoretically so then um we do some
experiments at the end to try to
understand a bit of the of that effect
but we just don't have a theoretical
handle
um okay so so just to highlight what the
kind of results are going to be about
they're they're going to be either
looking at descaling or with scaling uh
not both together
okay so this is the sort of
um kind of empirical result that I'd
like to work up to
um so
um let me explain what's being plotted
in these different plots so
um this is kind of the taxonomy that I
uh referred to uh earlier so if I and
these two by two kind of blocks uh
resemble are supposed to be kind of
experiments that correspond to the this
two by two grid over here so the
taxonomy is that if you're looking at
the scaling of one variable let's say
amount of training data or it could be
the the model size there's a regime
where there are basically two regimes we
have access to on the theory side
um or in our setup either the amount of
training data is the smaller of the two
variables it's sort of the bottleneck or
the amount of training data is
the larger of the two variables so as
you scale d
um you moved from this regime D much
much smaller than n to this other regime
and there's some crossover in between
which we can't access on the theory side
um but we gave these two different
regimes names
um which I'll kind of justify in a bit
depending on uh basically uh which
variable is the bottleneck and which
variable is
um not the bottleneck so when you're
scaling when you're studying the scaling
of a variable that is the bottleneck we
trim that a resolution limited regime
because there's a connection to some
data manifolds and properties of the
kind of
some spectral properties I'll I'll talk
about in a bit and when you're scaling
kind of the the larger variable you're
controlled just by a different limit and
so you're actually not gonna the
exponents That You observe are actually
um just kind of integer quantities
they're not as affected by the
microscopics of the problem
so I'm assuming that that when you talk
about empirical results it's got some
practically interesting learning tasks
what's the theoretical counterpart what
learning tasks are you looking at so um
so this so for this these experiments
are all image classification the like
The Benchmark tasks and actually uh
uh they're all kind of part of this was
to kind of aggregate different tasks and
show that some of them have a universal
exponent in some regions some don't for
the learning problem so part of what
um we do is we don't pause it
um
so we
we generalize it in part we we study a
student teacher setting so there's
teacher data that's generated by a
different network but apart from that
there are no other strong assumptions
other than power laws in certain
quantities in the data
so it's it's sort of um it's not
specified by a very like specific task
let's say that's like it's um but it's
uh
maybe the approaches that you posit the
distributional Assumption kind of comes
in on the Decay or the properties of
certain tensors matrices quantities
um that's where like the data assumption
is is
is hidden in the background basically so
so but still sorry to to follow up but
um somehow you're avoiding the fact that
there's there's certain problems which
are just uh intractable to learn yeah so
there must be some proxy for learning
that you have and what what's that proxy
look like
maybe the the
maybe it'll be clear in a couple steps
when I Define a problem but it is in a
student teacher setting so that there is
a teacher Network it's realized so it's
realizable
um that generates the data and that has
kind of the same form as the model that
learns and then on top of that
um there are going to be some
assumptions on the kind of properties of
that data which are related to power
loss
for these regimes are you uh
hearing the number of training examples
and the width of the model or and if so
how do you define a training example
such as any uh input Target pair that
you compute a gradient with respect to
yeah yeah that's right that's a good
question because this is going to come
back in in this setting you know D on
the order of n where that's basically
like a a small number or or one is the
kind of comparison you can make but then
to transfer that to other uh you know
like in the wild
um for a more complicated architecture
where this transition happens you know
how small is small and how large is
large is hard to say so that's going to
be something I'll come back to cool so I
I I think the point who mesh was making
was like if you had tried to learn a
pseudo-random function for example then
these loss curves would just be flat
yeah they would never go down right so
then you know there's the claim that
like there is a large class of practical
learning problems where this is you know
where the loss curves will look like
this
yeah and it's not it's not as formally
stated but the fact that this the the
setting where we have
a full handle is is a student teacher
setting uh and and so so the data itself
is generated by a teacher model and so
it's realizable you know that there is
generated
right but maybe we can let her get to
the nearest statement and then if it's
still mysterious weekend yeah I think I
think it will have an answer in a couple
sides but it's it's
um it's not a random function uh B it
has a structural property that will come
up
um but to to go back to what were the
results we're going to try to work up to
theoretically to match with what we
observe on the uh in the empirics is
basically this two by two kind of
classification so there's some regime
where exponents actually vary and depend
uh quite a lot on the problem you can
see here these are different data sets
um they're also different kind of
architectures being plotted here as well
as different losses and they have
different exponents and then some
regimes where the exponents are all
across these different settings are all
pretty close to one and similarly if you
look at the wind scaling
um if you you start from the regime
where with this kind of the smaller of
the two variables it's the bottleneck
and you transition to this other regime
which we turned variants Limited at some
point where the exponents are close to
one and so these are governed by
different different uh factors are just
driving these different these two
different versions uh which we tried to
give names to
any questions about this this spot can
you explain what you mean by resolution
limited and variance limited yeah those
terms came from also maybe I'll um say a
bit more about that it was just
motivated by kind of the idea that uh
in this regime you're it's kind of like
you're resolving a data manifold better
and better with higher resolution so
when you're adding you know if D is the
bottleneck variable and you're adding
you know you're increasing DD helps you
resolve this data manifold but at some
point you kind of saturate what you get
out of that and you you are controlled
by uh you approach a different limit and
um that's controlled kind of by
fluctuations around that limit how you
look is that more of an overfitting kind
of phenomenon
um
I don't know that uh
it doesn't necessarily I think it
doesn't have to be connected to
overfitting
um it's it's more about what just drives
the kind of approach to a limit
and these were kind of not being aware
of a classification or if this was um
you know if this sort of taxonomy exists
we we gave these names kind of based off
of our understanding from that simpler
problem
any other questions about this
okay so let me now say just a bit more
about the theory and what can we even
rely on from Deep learning theory so
um uh because this is a pretty
challenging problem so uh I will just
kind of mention for uh folks who might
not be as familiar with this area of
work there's been a lot of recent
progress in the past few years in deep
learning theory has been on studying
these large width limits of neural
networks so and going to infinity or I'm
pretty large
um and one of the findings has been that
this is a really a dynamical phenomenon
that's connected to the way that we
initialize and parametrize neural
networks that you get a connection
basically as you approach this limit the
model becomes more and more like a
linear model linear with respect to
parameters with random features that are
derived from kind of the the neural
network ad initialization so there's
still kind of a nice non-linear
um
set of random features
um but nonetheless you have a model
that's linear in parameters and also
another way to state that is that there
are some there's a relationship to
Kernel regression if you're doing if
you're using Square loss for example and
these are kind of Rich compositional
kernels that are derived from the neural
network architecture
um so because of the selection I
mentioned it's it's very much Dynamic
it's a dynamic phenomenon and it's
related to the way that we plan to try
it or initialize neural networks with a
particular scaling
um that that's been common in practice
so that this limit kind of kicks in at
some point
um this uh
this connection means that basically if
you for example have square loss you can
just solve the problem analytically and
rather generally so the solution you
know the the predictive uh function that
you get
um
for example this is a continuous time
version of it is just solving this
linear ode and you can do that in closed
form
um this ode here has this quantity k
which is a kernel
um and I've turned it King on because
it's derived from the random neural
network at initialization and so anyway
this is kind of a summary for a whole
body of work where you can drive and
study these different kernels
um where their recursion relations
governing what they are that depend on
the architecture
and this limit exists basically for kind
of a lot of different network types
where there's a natural notion of width
so fully connected layers convolutional
layers when that refers to the number of
convolutional filters residual networks
as well as attention layers although the
case of attention I think is sort of
interesting because I think the limit is
not as natural for for attention to kind
of get a similar limit you have to study
the limit of a large number of different
attention heads
um and so maybe it's a bit it stands out
as being a little bit different from
some of these other
architecture types I think
um
implications of being able to solve
these exactly just say so it's a for art
with with our theoretical tools it's
nice because you have an exact solution
to the predictive function and then you
can calculate things with that
and also it connects to I mean uh
certainly a lot of work in learning
theory kind of studies kernel regression
for example so this is basically kernel
regression when you're using Square loss
um and uh and you also know what K is
and it depends on the architecture you
can write down kind of recursion
relationships
so this is not this is a particular
solution let me let me say the more
General problem is actually a hierarchy
of differential equations that you would
have to solve for a deep neural network
uh with no obvious truncation for them
um
so can I ask you a sort of a funny
question so uh how would this relate to
what Ilya was saying yesterday you know
let's assume that you could actually do
these minimizations
Etc is that is that limited related to
this limit in any way
do which minimization you know so we're
Computing this the shortest program Etc
you know by completing the code number
of complexity so you know here you're
you're able to do a
you know give a close form solution so
is that does that in any way relate to
the
um
I think
I'd be a bit different
um
we know these mods okay also these
results are normal these results exploit
the learning Dynamics so it's like uh
important that we're doing SGD with a
certain step size so it's not really an
argument
yeah but yeah and we know it's very
supportive
it's a
one thing to say
I think that um
maybe like maybe perhaps the
sub-optimality depends on the amount of
data that you have access to uh for
example I'll try to say a bit more about
this but
um you know so
a model which doesn't
you know in general models have future
learning and feature learning uh I'm
going to Define it by just meaning that
this uh this quantity here K is really a
dynamical variable it depends on T and
there's also some equations governing
the Dynamics that you would have to
solve to really solve the full set of
equations
um uh now different regimes of learning
might have different amounts of you know
in different regimes you might have
different amounts of future learning
depending on how deep the network is how
wide it is how much training day you
have so these are all maybe they're also
again different regimes of learning this
is just
what I'm trying to summarize here is
that this is uh basically an exact
solution that kicks in as and when n is
pretty large relative to other aspects
of the problem like the amount of data
there's also a constraint on the
learning rate that I think Jacob was
mentioning as well
um but it's it's one of the best known I
mean in the sense that
it's been used in a lot of places I'll
talk about other places where I think
it's also relevant
um but uh the nice feature in in part is
that it's a pretty General solution so
then you can kind of separate out maybe
the the properties of the data with the
properties of the kernel
or or see how they're tied together
typically by studying this limit
um
any any other questions
thank you
actually I'll show I'll I'll show some
plots that kind of compare how at the
very end from empirical work kind of
comparing the performance of um
you know model where K is fixed versus a
model where K is allowed to change
dynamically and you can see how if
you're perhaps in an ultra low data
regime these models are pretty good and
so on but this is the the point of this
is is to see what can we learn from just
studying this model if you know is exact
and learned with and and and it's not to
get necessarily Precision predictions
out of it but to kind of understand this
tax line
thank you
okay
um
so let me maybe go more quickly through
this this um next few slides so just to
precisely say the the regime that we
study uh a bit more um kind of have a
full handle on this is a student teacher
regime it's a classic kind of setup uh
within learning theory and also kind of
uh statistical physics approaches just
to studying machine learning
um
uh so uh in our setup we have a teacher
model that generates some data
um
and generates the underlying data
distribution with d samples
and the student model learns from this
training data set we will assume student
and teacher models that are both linear
and their parameters and they use
arbitrary random features so this is
again this class of models that I
mentioned on the last slide so there are
some features Phi which are fixed
and random
derived from a random neural network and
you can construct a kernel out of that
uh from those random features and so
more specifically the teacher is a model
of this form these F's are the random
features
Omega ends are teacher weights that are
just drawn once randomly and then fixed
um uh potentially an infinite set of
features and the student model is a is a
particular class of
um you know it is is also constructed by
using some subset of the teacher
features and learning a linear model on
top of that so it's all within the class
of linear models with with random
features
um so maybe to if I can sort of follow
up on Shafi and Scott's earlier
questions and see if I understand how
one-way functions were ruled out is it
so let me tell me if this is kind of
correct so we're sort of implicitly
assuming that the data was generated by
some infinite with neural network that
started you know it was somehow obtained
by starting with random weights and then
doing some small learning rate limit and
in that limit
uh you can't really construct one-way
functions because everything is sort of
asymptotically linear and these random
features and so this is like if we had
like worst case overall incident with
networks then we would sort of be square
but because they're kind of the teacher
model is like implicitly something with
random weights then then you can't get
these one-way functions this is kind of
how we're rolling out uh the bad case it
could be so the weights certainly are
kind of they are drawn randomly they're
not fine-tuned to any specific problem
um the teacher Network could have
infinitely many features or finitely
many features but
um uh it is a linear model with random
features and there's going to be some
power law assumptions on the kernels
associated with these random features so
that's a diff that's another I think uh
reasoning I see that thanks that still
leaves the question of what functions
could we express if we could tune the
weights could we express anything that
way
uh so in in I think when it's infinitely
large I think you can resort to
Universal approximation if I understand
correctly
um but I think there are folks in the
audience who maybe have yeah
okay thanks
but the there is there is going to be
this important Assumption of the power
laws on on the Spectrum so what class of
functions
kind of are related to having that power
law assumption I think I don't know
they're um
they're basically yeah they're basically
well they're supposed to be a complete
basis when when you have infinitely so
for example if if you have the worst
case then even one of these would be a
worst case function
s right I think FM is the thing that is
like the solutions that you eventually
question on the left side no no no
um
no that wasn't that was just the the
predictor for a neural network these F's
are um uh
let's say they're they're a set of basis
functions
um and uh
maybe the one here's maybe one
constraint on on what they are uh which
is essentially like a distributional
assumption on the data
um
uh
which is that when you construct a
kernel from these um random from these
feature functions
um this is some kernel function you can
construct a if you looked at the
Spectrum of this eigenvalue spectrum of
this of the kernel Matrix you would
construct from that on the data that it
just follows uh this power law form so
um you know there this is true for I for
certain classes of F's and and not for
others
um does this maybe help with the
background assumption so this is the
this is one of the features of realistic
data that we wanted to work into the
model which is that when this is a power
law and this is kind of a generic
property
um you know sometimes in the theory
setting you would study kind of a bit
more pathological versions of this for
example there might be symmetries in
these eigenvalue degeneracies and so on
but these are not one of the points
you'd like to make is that this is kind
of not generic generically you have
um you know the these kinds of
quantities have nice power loss Spectra
and just in anticipation of the next
slide I've labeled the exponent
that you have asymptotically as as one
plus Alpha k
any questions about this so the if you
um
you know changing the the for example
this is an experiment that changes the
resolution of the images
um and when you course screen
um the problem it becomes simpler and it
is it changes this kernel exponent
these uh eigenvalues uh the Spectrum
these are for different data like what
are the different codes so it's just
it's a fixed architecture or fixed set
of um I think it's like a fully
connected it's a fully connected network
but it's just core screening so like uh
kind of
um
uh down sampling averaging you know over
images so that Tunes the kind of
difficulty of the problem
that's seen in the Spectrum okay yeah
that's and that's reflected in in the
Spectrum
so the more difficult problems have um
yeah the pool size means a smaller image
or
um
kind of more coarse grained image and
that has a steeper slope
and and uh with with kind of Greater
resolution you have a a shallower
okay so um
uh just to kind of move through this
section so given that onsets on the data
uh which I is motivated by experiments
so this is trying to kind of model
realistically these this some aspect of
the data then you can derive that the
data scaling exponent is Alpha k
um kind of to Leading order and the
width scaling is also Alpha K and so in
this setting you find that the exponent
is Alpha D and Alpha W are actually the
same
um they're kind of just controlled by
this one quantity that appears we call
this a duality and I'll come back to
this in an experiment in a couple slides
but so by setting this resolution
limited regime you can
kind of at least uh just
uh better understand that this scaling
originates from a power lot that exists
in the data and the model together it's
so it's really not talking about data
independently or model independently but
just the um this one quantity that
appears this is a typo I think yeah
these in the data
oh this uh no this uh so it's saying
that Alpha D is Alpha k
oh that's what you're saying uh yeah so
that's the result and Alpha W this
exponent is also equal to Alpha k
um just sir uh remember Lambda I is this
is an assumption about the student or
the teacher they use the same set of
features so the student is like a
projection potentially smaller set of
features but the whole collection of
features uh has this has this form
so this base is f
okay
um let me skip over kind of in the
interest of time some of these other
sections so uh that was what we called
this resolution limited regime we also
studied this a variance limited regime
where you're setting the scaling of the
variable that is not the bottleneck and
um kind of by looking at the ways in
which uh covariance finite size
covariance Matrix approaches its limit
you know the leading order kind of
expansions are are things that have
exponent one and so if you follow that
through into how it affects the loss you
get exponent integer exponent in one so
the finding is one of the points is that
in these different regimes are
controlled by different things one is
very data and model dependent the other
is controlled by just a nice kind of
basically uh you know uh one over n one
over N squared and so on expansion about
a limit
so this is um let me skip over this
slide as well this is just kind of a
sanity check on this specific kind of uh
setup where now we're looking at these
student teacher models kernels um it's a
special case of the experiments I showed
at the beginning so I won't uh dwell on
them uh further but again kind of the
results we're working up to are that
these exponents are one on the diagonal
and in this student teacher setting we
found that they were related to Alpha K
directly and that they're equal which is
what I call this duality
Okay so
a more general setting so there are two
aspects that can be generalized a we
could go beyond the student teacher
setting and have more of a genetic
generic kind of uh
function that generates the data the
other is to go beyond linear models to
include this important aspect of feature
learning and I'll comment on that at the
very end
um
uh so in terms of these two regimes the
variance limited regime and I won't um
go into the details of it is something
that we can show under more General
conditions so this exponent's equal to
one it doesn't rely on being in the
kernel limit so uh you can it because
it's unrelated uh basically to to
feature learning and it originates from
as I mentioned these leading order terms
about about a nice limit
um which where and to show this one of
the things we rely on is these leading
kind of finite with corrections to
infinite net with networks that's also
understood so this is kind of a more
robust kind of result for the resolution
limited regime for you know neural
networks in the wild where there is
future learning we lack a general form
for the predictor so it's not just a
linear model and instead I'm going to
try to uh we're going to try to rely on
hypotheses that we can test and expand
governments
um before I move on to that let me just
just mention one kind of pretty
realistic or I think uh kind of comes up
a lot a setting where you actually can
use find that these results carry over
and that's the one where you have
pre-training and fine-tuning
so um
uh let's suppose we have pre-trained
embeddings for example uh
embeddings that are trained on imagenet
and then fine-tuned uh on c410 and this
is kind of an experiment that's outside
our Theory because it's not the student
teacher setup there's no teacher
generating the correct labels and it
also uses learned embeddings
and uh we basically find that some of
these uh that the results I just talked
about for the exponents are robust so
here of course you see these Alphas
equal to one close to one but what's
surprising is that in this regime when
you look at data set scaling or model
size scaling the exponents are the same
um and so this Duality that I mentioned
didn't have to hold in this pre-training
fine tuning setup it's it's
um it's not a regime we actually have
control over but you find that as you
see here Alpha p and Alpha D
um uh are are uh pretty close so just to
kind of drive home the point
um about what's what's happening in
these plots as you change data set size
you're on one side of this curve that's
why we're kind of this is the regime
where data set sizes the bottleneck
variable and at some point if the
problem is not regular optimally
regularized you hit double descent
and and then later you cross over to
this regime where the exponents are
controlled by the variance limited
scaling so we're describing two
different kind of uh lim sides of a
double descent curve if you if you like
let's have a kind of historical question
here so if I understand correctly like
this implies that if you kind of have a
fixed amount of compute you should
always scale and D at the same rate as
that right so that's a a good are you
are you thinking about like Optimal
scaling yeah because this paper came
quite a bit before like the chinchilla
paper and uh openai had a co-author on
this paper but they were still using the
wrong scaly law so I'm just trying to
understand how those three facts are
reconcilable so it is kind of
tantalizingly close to the chinchilla I
think I think we can't say be as
definitive about that scaling law
because we're not studying our results
are for scaling of one variable at a
time rather than the joint scaling and
so I think you need to have access to
both
you know the full form L of D comma P to
be able to solve for you know given a
fixed compute what is the optimal way to
scale dnp but it is interesting that the
exponents are kind of this are the same
in this in this setting yeah
foreign
thanks for that question
um so let me
keep going
um so I find it surprising that this is
a setting as I mentioned it's outside
the theory we have learned a learned
model we have real embeddings they're
not teacher generated but you can still
observe The Duality uh between these
exponents and the resolution limited
regime
sorry I have a question so in the
student is
activity the loss goes to zero eight
minutes right but in the real world
cases that you are showing the loss
cannot go to zero it will bottom out at
some point because of the
variance right is that right
uh which which of these losses
into the right in these curves
go to zero or doesn't bottom out at some
point
uh if uh one so because one of the
variables is usually uh like finite
um so when you take the bigger if you
study the scaling uh for example this
variance limited regime you see I've
subtracted off
the asymptotic value
um in one of these plots and that's
because one of the variables is still
held fixed so you're kind of limited by
that
um I have maybe five minutes ten minutes
uh yeah maybe to leave time for
questions
[Music]
um let me then skip over just give that
a high level and I can talk about it
more offline the way in which you would
um try to generalize some of these
results so we um tried to then you know
in the wild when we don't have when
models don't behave as linear models you
can try to relate things some of these
exponents to numerical measures of
dimensionality of the data manifold
um so we did
um some things in that
um Direction but to kind of wrap up let
me go back to kind of the the in
experiments we wanted to work up to so
we did actually explain you know where
these Alpha equal to one exponents come
from and in the resolution limited
setting we have some control some
understanding of why these exponents
um you know take on the values that they
do and there's some relationship between
Alpha W and Alpha D that you can observe
for example in pre-training and
fine-tuning
um
maybe I'll skip over a few
um more experiments so we've looked at
experiments trying to change uh just
empirically changing the task for
example super classing a task when
there's kind of a fine to course
hierarchy and labels how that changes
the exponents uh it keeps for example
the exponents in variant and just shifts
the plots up and down whereas when you
put out
inputs you see much stronger effect on
the exponent so maybe one hypothesis is
that neural networks primarily model the
input data manifold less so the
classification task if you also look at
changing architecture for example you
change the width of the the models you
see a larger change in the exponent
compared to for example changing the
depth and this sort of thing we know is
is understandable it's connected to
models approaching kind of this kernel
limit that I described where there's no
future learning and when there is future
learning they become more sample or
parameter efficient
um okay so what are we missing from Deep
learning theory I mentioned
um that a lot of you know the the reason
we could do analytics using our tools
was because we could we can solve this
problem which is exact in a certain
limit but it lacks this aspect of that I
mentioned where K is really a dynamical
variable that changes from its initial
value
um so it's difficult to tackle this
problem in full generality and I'm not
sure that it's going to be tractable to
study
um kind of uh
you know generalization in a very
general way when you have future
learning I'll just mention
um uh you know in physics language since
there are a few folks with physics
backgrounds in the audience audience
that this kernel limit is sort of like a
non-interacting problem
or exactly solvable problem and it's
related to gaussian field theories and
linear problems so these are all things
that we can solve and these other limits
are strongly interacting
um and uh
you know uh so people have tried to use
techniques from physics
um to study these other kind of limits
where there might be feature learning so
techniques from correlated physics where
you have say you define some partition
function and try to kind of have some
mean field theory that is
self-consistent to be able to solve this
um but you can't it's difficult to solve
in full generality and so when you make
approximations for a particular
architecture or a particular type of
data it might not be clear how to
generalize that to other problems so I
hope I kind of convince you that we can
gain some things from studying this
simple setting we can understand some
you know a regime where there's some
Universal Behavior we can understand
some aspects of Duality that affect
pre-training and fine-tuning
um but we can't capture all the things
for example uh fully understand future
learning and here's uh just a plot that
shows the effect of future learning
going back to the question of is it
optimal or not so uh this plot shows
kind of the performance difference
between one of these kernels versus a
finite size neural network that's
trained that that's the blue curve
versus the green and you see that
there's a certain data set size critical
data set size where the performance of
the neural network is better than the
kernel but um it's equivalent kernel but
this but in a very kind of small
training data set training data size
regime the kernel can be better
so there's some crossover point where
one kind of uh overtakes the other
okay
um this is sort of a summary slide
and to revisit the questions I asked at
the beginning so I hope you kind of walk
away maybe with the the thinking that
difference gaming regimes are governed
by different driving factors or driven
by different factors and so you can kind
of have a taxonomy of different scaling
regimes
um
a number of open questions
which I'll also skip
through I actually really wanted to talk
about emergence and phase transitions
um
but I'm almost probably honestly yeah
I think maybe let's say questions and
um but I'm happy to talk more about this
well I wanted to you know a lot of what
I covered now was um
it was not directly studying llms it was
trying to do more first principles
Theory and simple setups I wanted to
kind of uh
um kind of pivot into some of the
discussions that were happening related
to conversations from yesterday but also
kind of tie it back to some things from
I so my training is in condensed matter
of physics and so I kind of like to look
at some of these things from from that
perspective
um and I wanted to make just a few
remarks about it
um okay so to kind of pivot you know I I
talked about loss
um and that's uh and it's really like an
indistribution problem and not out of
distribution generalization and and all
of this
um but now you know in this era of llms
we're also looking at just abilities so
different metrics accuracy as well I
didn't talk about accuracy on a problem
for example so you know you might
observe very nice improvements and loss
as a function of the scaling variables
but the performance is function of
accuracy when you study it might be
quite a bit sharper
um
I just wanted to highlight some of the
results from this big effort across a
number of different institutions that
was called Big bench how many folks are
familiar with big bench okay many people
so then maybe I don't need to to talk
about it but
um uh I wanted to show a few slides
about the way um uh kind of looking at
some of the results I think that this is
like a great effort to turn claims about
availability into you know more
scientifically measurable uh quantities
something that you can evaluate
um I think it gen it brings up an
interesting question of how to generate
interesting and diverse tasks in a
scalable way so not through just human
annotation of different tasks
um but for example a lot of these tasks
are programmatically generated by
individuals and so if you want to test
something like
um you know this might be doing human
annotation for images and so on might be
quite natural but if you want to for
example test scientific reasoning in a
more complex way
um then
um you know you could do that by looking
at high school textbooks and kind of uh
curating question answers from textbooks
but it's difficult it's challenging
challenging to generate a diverse set of
benchmarks that really probes more
deeper scientific reasoning without
doing it by hand so I think that brings
up kind of an interesting
um
uh thing to think about
um so this paper kind of highlighted
this uh fact that uh tasks you know can
have different
uh behaviors some might behave linearly
as a function of something on the x-axis
so it could be model size
um in in some of these or some might
have breakthrough behavior in quotes
um and some might even just get worse
with scale
um here's another example
um actually also really some big bench
tasks but this is from a different paper
also showing this kind of uh you know
what's being called emergent behavior
um for different tasks as a function of
some way of scaling on the x-axis which
could be model size but it could also be
other other ways of scaling
um
so I think one thing to note
um kind of a remark from the big bench
paper but also studied in more depth in
this paper by Schaefer at all is kind of
the dependence of these emerging
abilities on just simply changing the
metric
um so if you measure it kind of uh with
something very sharp uh that is
non-linear discontinuous like getting an
exact string match it can be quite sharp
if you change the metric
um they found that many of these kind of
uh
sharp uh sharp behaviors that were
observed in the big bench could be
reduced if you if you simply change the
metric so I think it brings up
interesting questions about uh when is
the behavior actually sharp and what is
the source of non-analyticity so I just
wanted to maybe say a few comments about
that um
so there are two kinds of I Notions I
think that
um are naturally connected to ones that
uh uh maybe come up in physics sometimes
there are claims about relationships to
phage transitions for example
um in this literature uh rather at an
informal level
um I wanted to mention that you know the
reason in uh kind of give say a little
bit about the fact that in physics uh
the origin of the non-analyticity That
You observe is because there's a
thermodynamic limit that you that you
deal with so for example in in physics
and statistical mechanics you have a
partition function that is a sum a
finite sum over analytic functions
and you always work in this
thermodynamic limit where the number of
the system size the number of particles
number of states goes to Infinity first
before you study uh kind of the thing
that Tunes you through a transition for
example tuning through a critical
temperature
so that's the source of non-analyticity
in these sorts of Transitions and to
establish it carefully in numerics or in
experiments usually you do finite size
scaling so you study how the system how
one of how with a changing system size
the The observed variables the measured
variables become sharper and sharper
um so I think to put some of this these
observations on a more uh kind of
rigorous footing you might want to do
things like things of that form uh and
basically just try to identify the
origin electricity if it does indeed
exist so
um it could be due to the metric perhaps
um it's not due to the metric and there
are some other variables there are
indeed non-analytic but I think this is
a place where Theory can do interesting
work because by taking the right limits
you can
um kind of get non-analytic Behavior
so that's maybe a comment about uh
sharpness and whether there is indeed
kind of
sharp Behavior that's setting in or just
gradual behavior that we simply don't
observe in experiments or aren't
measuring kind of the right quantities
for
um and I'll maybe just close by kind of
contrasting the approach I took this in
this talk with you know other approaches
that you might try to take
there's a lot of references these days
in the llm literature to kind of this
defining paper for
can that kind of defines the spirit of
condensed matter physics and just the
idea of emergence more generally
um across different Sciences
um where uh you know um at every level
uh as as you grow up in Scales at every
um stage you need
um you might have qualitatively new
Behavior set in that also requires new
theoretical language or a new
theoretical starting point that is not
easy to derive from more microscopic
kind of behavior so for example solid
state or money body physics kind of
emerges from particle physics chemistry
from many body physics and so on
um so I think it's I and I know other
speakers will talk about this later it's
it's an interesting time to think about
what are appropriate useful or
insightful formalized Notions of
emergence
um and the approach that I took in this
talk was really some combination of
trying to be first principles uh about
things using theory that we know but
also trying to do induction in some
stages when to fill in the gaps so
making a guess about the answer and then
trying to test it in experiments but it
might be that there's it would be more
appropriate to start with different
conceptual or theoretical Primitives to
say a useful predictive things kind of
in this in this current ERA for llms and
so um maybe I'll just I'll end there
[Applause]
amazing
maybe if there's one burning question
while Sasha sets up
a few years
up too much but